es tarde me siento un poco dormido pero
por otra parte me siento muy motivado y
motivado de una manera extraña no sé
igual y estoy poseído no sé pero
motivado a resolver problemas de ese
arte así que vamos a resolver problemas
de ese tema y está genial porque vamos a
empezar un nuevo examen vamos a trabajar
con el examen 2 y vamos a empezar con la
sección 3 que está en la página 459 de
este libro que como se llamaba este
libro o si o si la guía oficial de
estudio de ese arte y bueno estamos en
el problema número uno vamos a empezar
los y dice sí 3 b más 1
esto es menor que 10 entonces cuál de
los siguientes incisos no cumple esta
desigualdad y déjame ponerte aquí los
incisos el inciso a es menos 1 el inciso
p
pero el inciso sem es 1 el inciso d es 2
y el inciso m es 3 cuál de estos incisos
no cumple esta desigualdad entonces
quiero que te des cuenta que hay una
primera forma de resolver este problema
si nosotros sustituimos en cada uno de
estos valores y vemos cuál de los
valores de b no cumple esta desigualdad
pero eso se ve un poco tardado así que
mejor voy a trabajar con esta expresión
que tengo aquí esto es lo mismo que
decir que 3 b es menor que 10 menos uno
si resto uno de ambos lados de esta
desigualdad 3 b es menor que 9 o dicho
de otra manera si divido ambos lados de
la desigualdad entre 3 me va a quedar
que b es menor que 3 recuerda que como
estoy dividiendo entre un número
positivo en la desigualdad se conserva
que el número de estos números que tengo
aquí es menor que 3 y bueno menos 1 es
menor que 30 es menor que 3
32 es menor que 3 033 no es menor que 33
es igual a 33 es igual a 3 por lo tanto
este es el que no cumple mi desigualdad
3 no es menor que 3 y por lo tanto ya
está es el inciso m y bueno vamos a
resolver aquí creo que todavía me cabe
tengo bastante buen espacio vamos a
ahorrar
en esta ocasión no es papel es pizarrón
y aquí voy a hacer el problema 2 el
problema 2 que me dice 2 elevado a la 4
x esto es igual a 16 2 elevado a la 4 x
es igual a 16 y me preguntan cuánto vale
x y bueno esencialmente cuando yo tengo
una ecuación donde me importa está en el
exponente la magia de estos problemas es
escribir los dos lados de la desigualdad
en la misma base aquí tenemos dos el
llamado de 4x es igual a 16 y acaso
habrá forma de escribir el 10
6 como una potencia de 2 y bueno la
respuesta es que sí porque recuerda que
2 elevado a la primera potencia es 2 2
elevado al cuadrado es 4 2 elevado al
cubo es 8 y 2 elevado a la cuarta
potencia es 16 entonces me quedaría que
2 elevado a la 4x es lo mismo que 2
elevado a la 412 elevado a la 4 es lo
mismo que 16 y bueno si de esta parte yo
tengo que 2 elevado a la 4 x es igual a
2 elevado a la 4
ya me suena a que 4x tiene que ser igual
a 4 vamos a ponerlo aquí 4x tiene que
ser igual a 4 para que se cumpla esta
desigualdad y entonces dividiendo a
ambos lados entre 4 me va a quedar que x
es igual a 1 que por cierto si está en
nuestras respuestas y esto me hace
sentir la seguridad de que vamos bien y
de que tengo la respuesta correcta así
que déjenme borrar este pizarrón y vamos
a hacer el siguiente ejercicio
el cual dice lo siguiente y es muy
gracioso porque tengo la sensación de
que me va a dar gripa y espero que no
porque estar enfermo limitaría mi
habilidad de hacer vídeos del este en
youtube así que bueno el problema 3 dice
que tanto más grande es r 5 que r - 2
vamos a apuntar lo aquí r
+ 5 que tanto más grande es que r menos
dos que r - 2 y bueno esencialmente
cuando te digo que tanto más grande es
un número que otro por ejemplo aquí si
yo te digo que tanto más grande es 10
que 5 lo que te estoy diciendo es a qué
distancia está el 10 del 5 o por cuánto
es más grande el 10 que el 5 y para
averiguarlo lo que realmente haríamos es
tomarnos la diferencia 10 menos 5 esto
es igual a 5 y por lo tanto 10 es 5
unidades más grande que 5 de igual
manera aquí si yo lo que quiero saber es
que tanto más grande es r 5 que erre
menos 2 me voy a tomar la diferencia
para averiguar
y más grandes entonces r5 ya esto le voy
a restar hay que tener cuidado con los
signos a esto lo voy a restar r - 2 y
que me dan
bueno pues menos por más me da menos
menos r - por menos me da más +2 y aquí
tengo r 5 y lo bueno de esto es que se
va a cancelar la r y entonces está r
cuando ésta y reservar y me queda 7 es
decir que era 5 es más grande que r
menos 2 por 7 unidades y bueno también
hay otra forma de resolver este mismo
problema podríamos darle un valor
numérico a r el que nosotros queramos y
ver qué tanta diferencia hay entre estos
dos valores por ejemplo si yo digo que r
vale 0 entonces realmente lo que me está
preguntando es qué tanto más grande y
déjame ponerlo aquí que tanto más grande
que tanto
más grande más grande es cierre vale 0
aquí me quedaría 5 que tanto más grande
es 5 que menos 20 menos 2 me daría menos
dos menos dos y esta sería mi pregunta
que tanto más grande de 5 que menos 2 y
bueno utilizando la misma lógica
tendríamos que tomar la diferencia de 5
menos menos 2 lo cual es 52 que es
llegamos a la misma respuesta y tú lo
podrás verificar con cualquier otro
valor de hecho también existe una
tercera forma de ver esto que sería con
una recta numérica y bueno no podemos
ver todas las formas de resolver un
problema así que vamos a pasar el
siguiente problema que es el problema
número 4 que por cierto es un problema
bastante visual
el problema me dice que tengo una caja
así que déjame intentar hacerlo con
nuestra herramienta y vamos a esperar
que me salga lo mejor posible
tengo una caja como ésta aquí tengo un
lado tengo otro lado está grabarán tengo
otro lado por acá muy bien y después
tengo otro por acá entonces tengo a esta
caja vamos a hacer la otra parte de la
caja aunque lo que no está tan difícil
con esta herramienta me queda mejor aquí
mejor por acá y mejor por acá por cierto
esta caja no tiene tapa y bueno lo que
vamos a hacer con esta caja
esencialmente es visualizarla abierta lo
que vamos a hacer es desarmarla entonces
para desarmarla voy a tener que cortar
estas partes de aquí voy a tener que
cortar esto supongamos que estas me
dijera voy a cortar esto de aquí no
tengo tijeras pero esto me va a ayudar a
que lo visualices ahí además nos dan los
datos de cuánto vale cada lado este lado
baja
2 este otro para medir 3 y este de que
va a medir 4 y además vamos a hacer que
esta caja se desarme y para desarmarla
este lado lo voy a mover para acá éste
para acá este otro lo voy a sacar para
camps y este para acá es un problema de
visualización y cuál de las siguientes
opciones es la correcta
es decir voy a desarmar esta caja para
que veamos qué opción es la correcta así
que manos a la obra vamos a intentar
construir esta caja más o menos así está
mi base con el mejor pulso posible más o
menos por aquí va am y ahora uno de
estos dos y aquí me quedo sobrando un
pedacito pero ahorita lo borro vamos a
borrar este pedacito muy bien y ahora
vamos a poner cada una de las caras por
ejemplo este borde de aquí va a
corresponder en mi caja desdoblada a
este borde de aquí este es el que mide 3
ahora si me fijo en este otro borde que
tengo aquí este que voy a pintar de
verde ese mismo va a representar a este
otro borde de verde
voy a dibujar aquí este de aquí que por
cierto mide 4 y si ahora quiero poner
cada una de las paredes de la caja
entonces que me va a quedar que esta
pared de la caja esta que voy a pintar
con color rojo rojo rosa no se que sea
pero esta de aquí me va a dar estar acá
entonces esta es justo esta misma
recuerda que aquí todo el problema es la
visualización esta otra pared que estoy
dibujando de color verde esta es esta
misma esta pared que estoy dibujando
justo aquí está y por cierto este borde
vale 2 y si ahora me fijo en las paredes
de atrás vamos también a ponerlas es muy
importante que pongamos todas las
paredes vamos a desdoblar por completo
esta caja así que esta pared es lo mismo
que esta otra pared que voy a dibujar
justo ahorita más o menos así ok
este borde más de 2 también y por último
si yo me fijo en esta otra pared que voy
a poner aquí con un poco de líneas para
que reconozcas que es esta misma va a
ser esta en esta caja desdoblada y le
voy a poner las mismas líneas para
la uvic es entonces así se va a ver mi
caja es doblada que por cierto aquí las
respuestas está como el inciso el este
es el inciso m y bueno de hecho el
inciso es se ve más o menos así déjame
ponértelo para que no te confundas el
inciso se va a ver algo muy parecido a
esto donde te dicen que este lado mide 3
este otro lado mide 4
aquí te dan un valor de 4 a donde estás
déjeme agarrar otro color y aquí lo voy
a poner aquí te van a dar que este lado
mide 4 y el grosor mide 2 entonces lo
único que pasa de esta caja que yo te
dibuje aquí a la derecha al 16 es que la
caja gira 90 grados es decir que este
lado equivale a este lado este otro lado
equivale a este otro lado lo único que
estoy haciendo es girando esta caja y
entonces realmente lo que hice fue girar
esta caja 90 grados
hice una rotación de 90 grados y nos
vemos mejor en el siguiente vídeo
cuídate